didn't you have to spend endless hours
in your room practicing this guitar to
become a virtuoso which you are i used
to spend
12 hours a day there was a period like
12 hours a day right it's not it's not
because you i mean for me personally
it's not because
you know you go okay
it's it's whatever time nine o'clock in
the morning or something i start now and
then there's a lunch break and then i
get done no you were a kid who was
obsessed with your targets yeah so every
every waking moment i spent with you and
what was it that inspired you i mean
what was it that said it made you say i
want to play the guitar um it's long
story i i what happened was steve adler
the original drummer for guns n roses he
and i met when we were about 13 and we
started we basically ditched the seventh
and eighth grade together and just
uh we're best friends and he had a
guitar a little cheap guitar electric
guitar
and uh a cheap little amplifier and he
had a little turntable and he used to
crank kiss
you know as as loud as it would go and
then turn the amp up and he didn't know
how to play but he would just bang on it
and it was the excitement of that that
did that started that whole sort of um
you can imagine teenage thing where it's
like oh yeah we gotta start a band do
you think that you had exceptional
musical talent or was it this
unbelievable dedication to practicing i
think no and i think uh basically i was
raised you know raised on a lot of music
because my parents were in the music
business and i
loved rock and roll from the minute i
can remember um
and then when i actually picked up the
guitar and put those
realistically three notes together that
make a rock lick that had that rock
sound to it right i had a knack for it
did you did you ever take a professional
lesson from a teacher i tried to yeah
yeah and it didn't work well well what
happened is is i had this guy what when
i started when i was getting out with
steve was he was gonna play guitar and i
was gonna play bass right so i went to a
local music school that was in the
neighborhood and i went in there without
an instrument and i said i want to learn
how to play bass and the teacher was
like well do you have an instrument i
said no so he started talking to me
about trying to get into my head about
what i knew about music where i was
headed what i wanted to do and while he
was talking he was strumming the guitar
you know and playing some hendrix licks
yeah i said that's what i want to do
and did you ever learn how to formally
read music not not very much you know i
mean i started out with the basics when
i was in the music school he sort of
taught me some rudimentary stuff that
was really handy you know i learned how
to
uh string a guitar because my first
guitar only had one string and uh is it
mostly is it mostly by ear that you
played even with guns and roses like you
would hear something in your head and
then you would just try to figure it out
on the guitar it started you know it
starts out like piano lessons scales you
know
you're trying to read music right and
that didn't sound anything like what i
wanted to do so i i noticed that he
could listen to any song that i would
give him and he could pick it up and
learn it from by ear i said i can do
that and that's and i quit school and i
went and did it on my own so if you need
to learn a piece of music you just
listen to it yeah yeah and so when we're
writing stuff for say any number of
bands that i've been in or i go and do a
session with
any number of artists i just go in and
do it by ear the only person that i went
in and worked it worked with that i had
to do let me guess michael jackson no
ray charles he wanted you to what read
music no he i had to read chord charts
you did yeah and was that difficult it
was it was yeah ray charles chord charts
are not like anybody's chord charts
these are very comp the reason i had to
read the chord charts was to actually
remember how many all the different
chords because there's so many and
they're all jazz chords which i hardly
ever use so when you went into a session
with michael jackson let's say he would
play you a piece of music and say hey
slash see what you can do with this yeah
he would give me um an arrangement and
then he would go
you know do whatever you want and he
would leave